hey archaeologists let me say something
to you guys all right [__] you
I'm tired of all your [__] man why
because you have [__] education and
all that stuff if him and I find a
[__] Ark if you know if if him and I
find the Goblet or the fire National
like yeah
whatever if we found a slab of anything
with [__] things on it you know what
I mean it's ours and we're gonna sell it
baby [__] you my um great uncle was the
original Tomb Raider right so what but
the reason that why yeah his name was
Laura
no yeah all right anyway his name was
Byron the pro Rock and he was like the
OG like Tomb Raider yeah but it's
actually not as cool as the movie makes
it seem because he was just a rich boy
who had the money and the means to kind
of unearth the travel the world and
unearth all of these treasures and he
took them so like the the archaeological
Community really was like hey you can't
[__] just Waltz in here and you're
like some pseudo [__] you know some
pseudo archaeologist what is pseudo like
like fake oh real pseudoscience oh okay
let me ask you something but but
like Bobby like if you had the means and
the money you're just like I'm gonna go
to Tunisia and just like start digging
for what I think there's a ruby down
here no I don't think I would do that
what I have to do research first I'm not
gonna just blindly go to some
Desert Golf so that's where my grandma
was buried and she was apparently buried
with like an insane amount of Ruby
carrots so your uncle went to go and
raid that no oh yeah we should rate it
where was she buried Tunisia we got to
get it we gotta get it yeah well the
only thing I know is that it it is in
the same town where Sophia Loren Used to
Vacation so I was I was looking that up
because I was like well [__] like I want
to exhume a [__] let me okay so let's
let's if we started a our own
archaeologist firm company yeah yeah
right and I'll let's just talk about the
things we want to try to get here yeah
so here's what I think is going to be
worth a lot of money okay and this is
real
would you the knife that killed Jesus
okay the sheath or no remember he got
stabbed on the side right oh I didn't
know that well they were here to cut
there how did that happen tell me how
that happened he was the Romans pinned
him to the thing the cross check right
right check right and then they stabbed
him in the stomach with a knife check
right where is that knife
but we find it that's got to be worth
three thousand dollars like are you sure
Black Market yeah what do you think what
would you charge for that honestly yeah
yeah start with a million yeah you would
think it's only one of them yeah the
only one I didn't have duplicates I
would sell it back to the cat I would
sell it back to the Catholic church and
they have all the money in the world
right
so we got to get all that [__] how about
the [__] nails
how does one authenticate it though you
would have to be in cahoots with
um somebody who already wants a piece of
that pie yeah but I also think that
there's still Jesus is blood on the
thing and they can't analyze it oh yeah
can they not they should be they should
be able to do it so they have it check
out this this is pure Danity at Jesus
DNA
no um a little hard I'll just run it
through 23andMe exactly we'll put it in
the [__] we mail it we mail it like
the analyzer what do you think would
come up with yeah but imagine who it was
obviously three percent Native American
oh for sure always always
imagine what no I'm just saying imagine
if you swab that cloth and then who it
would be linked back to oh my it'd just
be one person right oh dude imagine I'm
just thinking what if they called you
you're the closest
descendant to Jesus guy you know what it
it's funny you say that really is it
funny that he says that I can't wait to
hear what you're about to say yeah
what's the follow-up you're the first
person to say that from aesthetically
two okay he's probably closer to what
Jesus looked like honestly yeah I mean
that's the most
I don't want your friends to be mad at
me okay because I'm trying to be about
love right yeah but that's all those
arrogant [__] thing I've ever heard
in my [__] life you think that you're
the closest looking to Jesus in this
room probably okay
I think
yeah no you're right yeah yeah yeah
you're right look at the hair real quick
yeah yeah you're right you guys come on
yeah yeah yeah
can I be honest with it if Jesus looks
look like you back in the day yeah I
don't think he would go under as much
followers really
no you would have got more if you look
like you think you got more I don't know
bro comment I mean your eyes are so
close together I don't know man I hate
that all right guys was his okay where
was his
was it just I don't know I beat me
neither yeah I don't know what the guy I
don't know what he looks like maybe that
was a thing that's a thing all right
yeah listen I don't I love you I want
your friends to like me and so you look
good looking guy but I'm just saying
okay what else could we sell find as a
archaeologist well a [__] would be I
mean a ship like a full a full vessel of
some sort right you know just maybe a
submarine or something you just open up
just black taped bags
drugs
now we're thinking now we know now we're
really move you know all right we didn't
know how to sell that yeah because if we
got Jesus's knife right it'd be like how
do we how do we call well they come and
find you the Freemasons would find you
they have a whole Explorers Club yeah we
be [__] up yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
interesting so what if we found um do
you think if we found Hitler's mustache
you think his mustache is haunted
am I the one yeah probably what if I
found it and I put it on mine just as a
joke oh I would not do that that'd be
funny it's like haunted as much as it's
like bad juju yeah like bad energy right
stay away from it yeah it's the same
reason why I always think twice before
like bringing anything back from an
antique store like I have to hold it and
see if it feels good I know you see in
the movie I know you've seen the movie I
have seen all of
yes right what movie are you referred to
tell me who in their right mind would
see Annabelle doll yeah there we go this
is cute yeah